I'm going to talk about how a I and
mankind can coexist but first we have to
rethink about our human values so let me
first make a confession about my errors
in my values it was 11 o'clock
December 16th 1991 I was about to become
a father for the first time my wife
Shandling lay in the hospital bed going
through a very difficult 12-hour labor I
sat by her bedside but looked anxiously
at my watch and I knew something that
she didn't I knew that if in one hour
our child didn't come I was going to
leave her there and go back to work and
make a presentation about AI to my boss
Apple CEO fortunately my daughter was
born at 11:30
sparing me from doing the unthinkable
and to this date I am so sorry for
letting my work ethic take precedence
over love for my family my a I talk
however went off brilliantly Appel loved
my work and decided to announce it at
Ted 1992 26 years ago on this very stage
I thought I had made one of the biggest
most important discoveries in AI and so
did the Wall Street Journal on the
following day but as far as discoveries
went it turned out I didn't discover
India or America perhaps I discovered a
little island off of Portugal but the AI
era of discovery continued and more
scientists pour their souls into it
about ten years ago the grand AI
discovery was made by three North
American scientists and it's known as
deep learning deep learning is a
technology that can take a huge amount
of data within one single domain and
learn to predict or decide at superhuman
accuracy for example if we show the deep
Learning Network a massive number of
food photos it can recognize food such
as hot dog or no hot dog or if we show
that many pictures and videos and sensor
data from our driving on the highway it
can actually drive a car as well as a
human being on the highway and weather
if we show this deep learning network
all the speeches made by President Trump
then this artificially intelligent
President Trump actually the the network
Kent
you like double oxymorons now
so this network if given the request to
make a speech about AI he or it might
say it's a great thing to build a better
world with artificial intelligence
and maybe another language you're going
to now John's a guy bada you didn't know
him know Chinese did you so deep
learning has become the core in the era
of AI discovery and that's led by the US
but we're now in the era of
implementation where what really matters
is execution product quality speed and
data and that's where China comes in a
Chinese entrepreneurs whom I find as a
venture capitalists are incredible
workers amazing work ethic my example in
the delivery room is nothing compared to
how hard people work in China as an
example one startup tried to claim
work-life balance come work for us
because we are 996 and what does that
mean
it means the work hours of 9:00 a.m. to
9:00 p.m. six days a week
that's contrasted with other startups
that do nine ninety seven and the
Chinese product quality has consistently
gone up in the past decade and that's
because of a fierce fully in competitive
environment in Silicon Valley
entrepreneurs compete very gentlemanly
in very gentlemanly fashion sort of like
in old Wars which in which each side
took turn to fire at each other but in
the Chinese environment it's truly a
gladiatorial fight to the death in such
a brutal environment entrepreneurs learn
and to grow very rapidly they learn to
make their products better at lightning
speed and they learn to hone their
business models until they are
impregnable as a result great Chinese
products like WeChat and way ball are
arguably better than the equivalent
American products from Facebook and
Twitter and the Chinese market embraces
this change and accelerated change in
paradigm shifts
an example if you any of you go to China
you will see it's almost cashless and
credit card lists because that thing
that we all talk about mobile payment
has become the reality in China in the
last year eighteen point eight trillion
u.s. dollars were transacted on mobile
Internet and that's because a very
robust technology is built behind it
it's even bigger than the China GDP and
this technology you can say how can it
be bigger than the GDP because it
includes all transactions wholesale
channels retail online offline going
into a shopping mall or going into a
farmers market like this the technology
is used by 700 million people to pay
each other not just merchants
so it's peer-to-peer and it's almost
transaction fee free and it's
instantaneous and it's used everywhere
and and finally the China market is
enormous this market is large which
helps give entrepreneurs more users more
revenue more investment but most
importantly it gives the entrepreneurs a
chance to collect a huge amount of data
which becomes rocket fuel for the AI
engine so as a result the Chinese AI
companies have leapt ahead so that today
the most valuable companies in computer
vision speech recognition speech
synthesis machine translation and drones
are all Chinese companies so with us
leading the era of discovery and China
leading the era of implementation we're
now in an amazing age where the dual
engine of the two superpowers are
working together to drive the fastest
revolution in technology that we have
ever seen as humans and this will bring
tremendous wealth and precedented wealth
16 trillion dollars according to PwC in
terms of added GDP to the worldwide GDP
by 2030 it will also bring immense
challenges in terms of potential job
replacements
whereas in the industrial age it created
more jobs because craftsman jobs were
Deeping decomposed into jobs in the
assembly line so more jobs were created
but AI completely replaces the
individual jobs in the assembly line
with robots and it's not just in
factories but truckers drivers and even
jobs like telesales customer service and
hematologist as well as radiologists
over the next 15 years are going to be
gradually replaced by artificial
intelligence and only the creative jobs
I have to make myself safe right really
the creative jobs are the ones that are
protected because AI can optimize but
not create but what's more serious than
the loss of jobs is the loss of meaning
because the work ethic in the Industrial
Age has brainwashed us into thinking
that work is the reason we exist that
work define the meaning of our lives and
I was a prime and willing victim to that
type of workaholic thinking I worked
incredibly hard that's why I almost left
my wife in the delivery room that's why
I worked nine nine six alongside of my
entrepreneurs and that obsession that I
had with work and that you abruptly a
few years ago when I was diagnosed with
fourth stage lymphoma the PET scan here
shows over 20 malignant tumors jumping
out like fireballs melting away my
ambition but more importantly it helped
me reexamine my life knowing that I may
only have a few months to live
caused me to see how foolish it was for
me to base my entire self-worth on how
hard I worked and the accomplishments
from hard work my priorities were
completely out of order I neglected my
family
my father had passed away and I never
had a chance to tell him I loved him my
mother had dementia and no longer
recognized me and my children had grown
up during my chemotherapy I read a book
by Ronnie where who talked about dying
wishes and regrets of the people in the
deathbed she found that facing death
nobody regretted that they didn't work
hard enough in this life they only
regretted that they didn't spend enough
time with their loved ones and that they
didn't spread their love so I am
fortunately today in remission
so I can be back at Ted again to share
with you that I have changed my ways
I now only work nine six five
occasionally 996 but usually in that six
five I moved closer to my mother my wife
usually travels with me and what my kids
have vacation that they don't come home
I go to them so it's a new form of life
that helped me recognize how important
it is that love is for me and facing
death helped me change my life but it
also helped me see a new way of how a I
should should impact mankind and work
and coexist with mankind that really
what we're a I is taking away a lot of
routine jobs but routine jobs are not
what we're about
we're why we exist is love when we hold
our newborn baby love at first sight
when we help someone in need
humans are uniquely able to give and
receive love and that's what
differentiates us from AI despite what
science fiction may portray I can
responsibly tell you that AI has no love
when alphago defeated the world champion
Korea while Korea was crying and loving
the game of Go alphago felt no happiness
from winning and certainly no desire to
hug a loved one so how do we
differentiate ourselves as humans in the
age of AI we talked about the axis of
creativity and certainly that is one
possibility and now we introduce a new
axis that we can call compassion love or
empathy those are things that a I cannot
do so as AI takes away the routine jobs
I like to think we can we should and we
must create jobs of compassion you might
ask how many of those there are but I
would ask you do you not think that
we're going to need a lot of social
workers to help us make this transition
do you not think we need a lot of the
compassionate caregivers to give
more medical care to more people do you
not think we're going to need ten times
more teachers to help our children find
their way to survive and thrive in this
brave new world and with all the
newfound wealth should we not also make
labors of love into careers and let
elderly accompaniment or homeschooling
become careers also this graph is surely
not perfect but the point says for ways
that we can work with AI air well pay I
will come and take away the routine jobs
and in due time we will be thankful AI
will become great tools for the
creatives so that scientists artists
musicians and writers can be even more
creative AI will work with human as
analytical tools that humans can wrap
their warmth around for the high
compassion jobs and we can always
differentiate ourselves with the
uniquely capable jobs that are both
compassionate and creative and using and
leveraging our irreplaceable brains and
hearts so there you have it a blueprint
of coexistence for humans and ai ai is
serendipity it is here to liberate us
from routine jobs and it is here to
remind us what it is that makes us human
so let us choose to embrace AI and to
love one another thank you
you
[Music]